an asteroid would have hit us and killed
us but he saved our lives right there
what right here watch when he saved
planet earth what i don't like bars i'm
gonna be like drinking
let me know
it's a that's the the the guy the dead
guy he
that's probably uh the first thing
you're gonna say and this first thing
most girls say is like
you like good hygiene
no
i mean okay
i think died to add to one of the
problems of i mean this guy is wait hold
on stop it he's always dying stopped in
the middle he started in the middle of
of the video mm-hmm play it again from
the beginning
jake man the guy from that machine says
probably uh the first thing you're going
to say and this first thing most girls
say is like you like good hygiene
i mean
i think died this guy dies
you know what happens positive he goes
back into he goes back in time
and and he experiences a whole year and
then comes back like or you know what i
mean like go to the future experiences a
whole year yeah and then fixes the world
and then comes back that's what happens
yes
like we would all died with an asteroid
would have hit us and killed us but he
saved our lives right there
go back go back and see how he saved our
lives what right here watch when he
saved planet earth like good hygiene
saved the planet saved humanity right
there one of the problems of
why
i had to ask for advice is because i'm
sure and you couldn't see that
answer for that
um
something safe humanity should we just
go for taller women or
i mean
you look shorter than your wife or is it
matt are you are you taller than yours
what i don't know if that's the issue
but i look shorter than my wife yeah you
look shorter than kristin hopefully just
not my hygiene i know that for a fact
but i don't know what should i go to
bars what i don't like bars i don't
really like drinking
see if humanity let me know saved
humanity three times we would have been
extinct all right
so it turns out that he's short okay
okay that's it first of all how short of
all i don't look shorter than kristen i
don't know dude this guy's got a couple
things going on
but
yeah he he is but also maybe be more
engaged sit up sit there talking to
people you know talk a little faster
don't maybe don't fall asleep in the
middle of sentences yeah i mean this guy
like this is this guy
yeah man i'm just thinking you know nice
meeting you at this bar you know maybe
we just hang out
[Laughter]
maybe we hanged out sorry i was tr so
what had happened was
in 40 years
she's just walking away already
in 40 years humanity is at a standstill
i had to go fix uh
basically all the sperm cap
scientifically i had to go fix the sperm
count in men because it was dying and it
was at the crux of the situation where
we was all going gonna be extinct anyway
what are you getting
my friends what's that
i'm gonna go join my friends
[Laughter]
thank you
i mean yeah the [ __ ] guy's just he's
sitting right it's right in front of him
dude you're a confident guy be be that
and talk to women and don't be a creep
that's so simple just those those things
all right you're good all right and yeah
if he's asking about hygiene and be
clean too yeah be clean but no but a
little bit of beard is good though yeah
girls say that because i don't know what
else this isn't like bad hygiene i know
people are always like oh crucially you
look like you don't shower bro i shower
oh yeah how about this i shower more
than you did yeah maybe i do i shower at
least once a day at least at least i
never go a day without showering never
ever ever i do what i would one day
without showering in the past however
many years
and it was when i got my nose surgery
jesus hey dude
oh you're all right you're [ __ ]
having a stroke
[Laughter]
all right dude
hello
[Music]
hello
[Music]